alors vous reprochez pas mal de choses
aussi avait une chose importante m'at-il
semblé de pierre mendès france
c'est ce cm 68 et charléty qui était
est-ce que c'est un mauvais souvenir
pour mai 68 on va voir quelques images
seraient c'est un mauvais souvenir en ce
sens que ça aurait pu être le moment
d'une mutation profonde sans conviction
sans drame
je crois qu'il aurait pu à ce moment là
se produire en france
grand changement auquel aspire à il faut
bien dire pas seulement les étudiants
dans tout le monde a parlé mais il faut
bien dire une immense masse de français
il ya eu tout de même 11 millions de
grévistes et qu'il faisait pas la grève
uniquement pour les salaires les grands
types disait quand il disait 10 ans est
assez ça voulait dire quelque chose
c'était pas seulement mettre un terme à
la présence de de gaulle c'était éprouve
un besoin de changement de
transformation ne savez peut-être pas
exactement où avec beaucoup de clarté ce
qu'il volait ya eu dans cette période
indiscutablement dans beaucoup d'esprits
pas mal de confusion et c'est là que le
rôle des hommes politiques auraient dû
être de proposer une solution de
rechange enfin une mutation
elle ne s'est pas produite en partie
parce que beaucoup des hommes
responsables je parle de l'opposition
n'en voulait pas en partie parce qu'il
ya eu d'énormes divisions et querelles
entre les hommes quittent et hostiles au
pouvoir mais qui pensaient beaucoup plus
à leurs difficultés à leur rivalité à
leur opposition à leur amertume alors
elle qu'à une modification de la
politique suivie par conséquent ça a été
une occasion perdue alors ce sens est en
effet une mauvaise elle c'est rené char
mauvais souvenir cela dit je continue à
croire qu'il aurait pu se produire
quelque chose et que le pays le
souhaitait et je le répète pas seulement
les étudiants là curieusement on parle
beaucoup des étudiants parce que ils ont
attiré l'attention
mais enfin au début ou quelques semaines
on s'est rendu compte que ça conduit
êtes au désordre et au chaos il ya
le mouvement d'opinion considérable en
sens contraire
mais au début il y avait une grande
attente et l'opposition n'a pas su
répondre à cette attente est en ce sens
un effet d'affaires a échoué alors bien
bien son compte et vous reproche une
chose d'horrible dans votre nom je ne
reproche rien jeu ce sont des lettres
ouvertes où j'essaye de dire comment
j'ai ressenti tel ou tel événement ou
tel ou tel homme au milieu de
circonstance je ne juge pas le
journaliste pour moi ne préside pas un
tribunal ou ne tient pas une chaire de
facultés il et il essaye d'être un
témoin et il essaye d'être un témoin
froid ceci dit il a aussi c'est ses
humeurs mais vous pensez que la présence
de pierre mendès france à charléty ce
jour nuit à son image de marque
c'est la question que lui à son image de
marque nous ont ce n'est pas cela je
crois que si vous voulez j'ai eu le
sentiment ce jour là je dis comme je les
ai ressenti que c'était trop et pas
assez vous y allez pas parler c'est ce
que vous étiez un peu face à des jeunes
qui espéraient que vous seriez l'honnête
gérant de leur révolution un peu folle
façade et à leurs parents qu'ils
espéraient que vous remettrez y ait des
choses un niveau raisonnable ou nez et
vous ne parlez pas et là dessus je
continue à m'interroger r vous
interrogez je crois que le jour de
charléty on peut presque dire que la
roue avait déjà tourné je vous ai dit
tout à l'heure dans une première période
tout était possible et puis et puis le
pineau s'est reprise et c'est à charléty
était à mon avis c'est déjà la deuxième
vérité déjà cela dit ma présence à
charléty s'explique cette jolie
l'expliqué 20 fois de deux manières
d'une part j'ai toujours été à l'affût
de mûrissement de ce qui se passait chez
les jeunes le réflexion des jeunes de la
protestation des jeunes du malaise des
jeunes j'avais besoin de comprendre ce
qu'ils voulaient par conséquent il me
semblait que je ne vais pas le droit de
ne pas me tenir au courant de ce qu'il
voulait dire ce jour là
si de ce qu'ils exprimeraient et quand
je dis que ce qu'il dirait exprimerait
je ne pense même pas tellement aux gens
qui parlent est à la tribune je pense
que je pense surtout aux réactions des
foules qui était là il y avait soixante
dix mille personnes des colossales des
syndicalistes des jeunes paysans
naturellement des étudiants due forme
tout son petit jaune tous
et puis deuxièmement et ça c'est un fait
très précis ou qu'elle jette auquel j'ai
attaché beaucoup d'importance
nous avons pendant quelques jours
pendant deux ou trois jours risque et le
pire ce que je veux dire
je veux dire par là risque et le sang
les hommes au pouvoir étaient exaspérés
par cette rébellion des jeunes qu'il ne
comprenait pas qui disait de gaulle
était insaisissable
c'est de mourir pouvait y est toujours
et à partir du moment où il espérait
régler la situation ouvrière par les
négociations de grenelle qui devait sa
chaîne s'achever lundi matin 27
le jour où ils seraient débarrassés du
problème ouvriers il l'idée était venue
certain nombre de mater par n'importe
quel moyen
la rébellion de la jeunesse et l'idée de
tirer
l'idée de réprimer avec dernière vigueur
rigueur est venu à l'esprit d'un certain
nombre qui ont tu vraiment l'intention
que je le répète du pire
à ce moment là un certain nombre
d'hommes ne tue pas le seul et même
quelques heures je dois dire au sein du
gouvernement ont tout fait pour essayer
d'éviter ce pire sans parvenir à
convaincre les plus grands responsables
et et celui qui au fond du riche de la
manoeuvre quitté le premier ministre à
ce moment là mais le jour de charléty
tout était encore à craindre
ce qui a finalement
entrez les responsables à ne pas prendre
la décision fatale ce jour là c'est que
la négociation grenelle n'a pas bien
réussi que allusive l'on a refusé
l'accord de grenelle enfin que la
situation ouvrière ne s'est pas trouvée
régler aussi vite qu'il l'aurait
souhaité et par conséquent ils n'ont pas
osé mater la révolte étudiante comme ils
l'avaient songer d'abord et c'est
seulement le lundi matin à la fin de la
matinée que les décisions ont été prise
de laisser la manifestation se faire à
condition que ce soit dans un lieu clos
quittez donc le stade charléty et qu'il
n'y aurait pas de répression qu'il n'y
aurait pas de police j'ai craint jusqu'à
la dernière minute que quelque chose se
produise vous savez une maladresse une
provocation d'un côté ou lier peuvent
toujours produire dans des situations
explosives de ce genre le pire et j'ai
voulu être là je me rappelle très bien
que je quittais charléty avant la fin de
la manifestation que j'ai un peu circulé
dans le quartier
j'ai constaté qu'il n'y avait pas de
police il y avait pas un policier avec
un camion n'y avait pas la parole donnée
a été tenu et des lions c'est pourquoi
il ya eu aucune violence car je tiens à
remarquer que dans toute cette période
il n'y a jamais eu de violence que
lorsqu'elle a été provoquée il n'y a
jamais eu de violence spontanée et donc
ce jour là finalement il ne s'est rien
passé ce qu'il était très bien même et
jusqu'à la fin on n'était pas sûr que ce
serait le cas et c'est la raison pour
laquelle mon devoir était d'aller là
cela dit contrairement à ce que vient
son pari croire il n'a jamais été
question qu'il prenne la parole la
veille au soir il ya eu une réunion d'un
certain nombre de personnalités qui joue
personnes qui jouent un rôle dans cette
affaire
pour débattre de ce corps serait le
lendemain la manifestation de charité
dont on ne savait d'ailleurs pas
exactement dans quelles conditions et
dans quel cas il pourrait se dérouler et
de quelle tolérance elle pouvait
profiter de la part des pauvres
blink et les tendances les plus
contraires les plus divergentes se sont
manifestés et militant syndicaliste très
important qu'il était là à employer
cette formule pour résumer le débat à la
fin si je comprends bien vous êtes tous
décidés à pousser ma des sceaux pouvoir
et vous êtes tous décidés à faire tout
ce qu'il faut pour que ça n'arrive pas
oui c'était très exactement c'était très
exactement l'organisation du meeting
je voyais que vous ne prendriez pas la
parole en effet mais vous sentiez vous
même cet appel d'ailleurs ces cris qu'on
entendait qui vous demandait de dire de
dire ce qu'il fallait faire à ces gens
je vous répète attendait que quelqu'un
leur je vous répète encore une fois vers
sable à ce moment là il était clair pour
moi que les hommes qui s'opposait au
régime étaient divisés et ne voulait pas
mettre un terme à leurs divisions que
par exemple
d'une part le les socialistes au fond
n'y croyais pas beaucoup ils voulaient
pas pousser les communistes étaient
parfaitement décidé à faire survivre le
système du gauchiste ne voyait que la
guérilla contre les communistes
enfin le débat entre eux était telle
qu'il n'était pas possible entre eux de
faire véritablement une renier l'esprit
d'une coalition
un tout